[Musik]
dann wollte er mit mir kaffee trinkt
wieso hast du sie nicht gemacht da hätte
es bestimmt auch die titelseite gebracht
hierauf ich schäme mich jetzt aber kein
wunder dass heutzutage niemand mehr
zeitung liest keine sorge die annoncen
aber trotzdem ein guter deal sie bitte
helfen
ich lese total gerne zeitung
und ich bin mir sicher ich bin nicht die
einzige
man liest du denn zeitung ich lese am
liebsten morgens dazu trinke ich dann
einer tasse kaffee oder abends vor dem
schlafengehen aber man liest doch
heutzutage alles im handy nach zeitungen
sind unpraktisch und einfach nicht mehr
modernen journalismus ist immer noch
extrem wichtig und zeitungen werden auch
immer wichtig seien die meisten
zeitungen haben heutzutage eine app die
meisten haben mich alle
was meinst du
[Musik]
ich begrüße sie ganz herzlich
mein name ist jose gonzales aber bitte
nennen sie mich bitte ich präsentiere
ihnen eine vollständige digitale lösung
für ihre zeitung
wir entwickeln für sie nicht nur apps
und internetseiten wir stellen ihnen
auch lösungen für steigende leserzahlen
vor die vielen vorteile liegen natürlich
auf der hand
mit der neuen app werden mehr leute ihre
zeitungen lesen
ich bedanke mich für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]